alright let's talk about everybody's
favorite kooky uncle Vice President Joe
Biden he was in Paris for one night and
I can't ask you to guess how much it
cost cuz i know you know already won he
was in one room and then you know
Service Secret Service detail a couple
other rooms five hundred and eighty-five
thousand dollars of your hard-earned
taxpayer money by Joe Biden was he
partying with Charlie Sheen no I heard
it was just the ugly American rate it
was the bad hair fund rate it was the
ugly American rate they've got a
separate column for that when you check
in yeah and they were like looked at
took one look at him and went oh boy
stick a couple of zeros on them put a
couple of zeros on me is there any
number that's too much lesser get
outraged do this stuff to be totally
fair they had to rent out the entire
floor cuz Joe has no inner dialogue yes
this little filter he'll just say it and
they have to keep him away from everyone
right you get a drink in the minutes
like sodium pentathol and the nuclear
the football codes all come out you know
so it's not even a security issue this
is purely a babbling everyone's his best
friend got to keep them somewhere on the
floor yeah I so want to know I so want
to know how they spent all that much oh
how could you do it you either one if
okay you're thinking you know those
jeroboams of champagne oh yeah you know
so you get a case of the Jeroboam so
start with I'm thinking right you know
then the Secret Service would get drunk
I try to shoot the cork off the top of
them when they're on a pyramid of flutes
you know now they said that the the
rooms at this at this hotel where 900
and night but 900 let's say you took ya
a hundred rooms thanks but that's the
little room which yeah it was
presidential suite okay so that's five
grand okay but say it's ten seats 10
yeah you still you still have a lot of
money to spend 500 500 thousand dollars
i'm thinking i don't know maybe he had
animals come in and just you know [ __ ]
everywhere
and and then the Moulin Rouge came in
and did can I I die I think it's
impossible to spend yeah I don't know
what do you think about how the media
treats this kind of stuff because I
sense we're all sort of lefty
progressive types here but if this had
been you know a Republican wasting this
kind of money everyone will be going
nuts right I'd love to see the itemized
hooker tally yeah that actually Secret
Service you know they were like but
fellas we're in France you know that had
to be the conversation that when is this
gonna happen again yes are hookers more
expensive or less expensive in France
that's what they do well once again it's
the ugly American rate man Americans are
just getting screwed everywhere nobody
likes it is there any country we can go
to now and be thought of better uh no
nobody think of one Canada yo Canadians
well I mean they like our their dollars
catching up to us like a pony they put
up with us nice don't they politely put
up with Canadians to Australia likes us
australia vs that's true they're kind of
even the uglier version of The Ugly
American down there China pretends not
to like us but they're crazy about us
well because they're gonna cash in the
debt one day that's a [ __ ] they need us
to be here too they're not going to war
with us they're not bombing their own
property exactly just gonna get the
Grand Canyon out and move it take the
rocky map right you have the sinkhole
yes all right well we went on a slight
sidebar here but I think the point is
that Joe is gonna keep doing these kinds
of crazy things and we just gotta roll
with it and see what I don't make Joe
into someone he's not just everybody
calm cause this perfect stop what stop
worrying about it he's not doing any
harm
don't forget bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
they've got great new slim fit shirts
I've never felt sharper enter code trr
20 for twenty percent off your first
purchase